[Music]
okay i'm gonna try well i don't have
much time i mean obviously let me let me
go let me challenge magnus i mean
i have technically like 40 minutes but
um
for really less than that and honestly
i'm gonna well i'll just tell magnus
that i i don't have much time i'm sure
he'll be fine with it
i'm sure he'll be fine with it magnus
i'm challenging but he's he's
still online not accepting and stuff
let's facetime him
all right let me call him really quickly
on whatsapp
hey magnus
yeah no i did challenge you
oh you're watching are you you're scared
oh okay well you should have told me
that immediately
okay well then i won't talk to you again
bye
anyways i'm sure he'll call me back
he'll call me back guys
i can guarantee you that magnus is not
gonna take that he'll call me back
any second i know how he acts
oh my god
i'm not i'm not answering i'm not
talking to people who are scared of me
i'm not talking to people who are scared
of me
not talking to people were scared of me
um rebecca oh my god
magnus i'm not hearing your excuses
i i don't want to hear excuses i want to
see you accept my challenge
and then we'll talk
looks like we might be on a little call
with somebody
i don't know we'll see i don't know
don't know i don't know yet
i don't know what's going on
here we go i did not expect this that's
for sure
hello are we on stream
we are i can't believe this
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna make this
really quick
absolutely the floor is yours so you
expect me to play you
now after you go on stream earlier today
insulting me saying that i'm running
away
that i'm scared to play you let me tell
you one thing
i was a gm i was a world champion
when you were doing pee pee in your
pampers
that's all right that's all i have to i
have to say
and after yesterday we play a few
nice games i give you some tips
and you go ahead flag me in one game i'm
tell
then i'm telling you go in your car
play from your phone you don't do it
instead you go crash the server and mess
up
everybody's day you're you're you're
you're not a good man
oh my god oh go screw yourself
thank you
oh my god
that's actually so hilarious
that is one of the most legendary
moments i've had on my stream
oh my god
that is that is just epic um first of
all it's
uh i don't know it's an honor i i'm
i am humbled that that magnus uh
that means magnus is listening to my
stream and that would
represent the peak of my the peak of my
abilities this is better than any 2700
really anything at all
that was definitely no that was him i
can i can uh i can confirm
i need to atone for my sins um
i need to atone for my sins and then
maybe
if i tone sufficiently i'll earn the
right to play him
um at some point in the near future
all right that's that's insane that's
absolutely insane
[Music]
you